hey guys Pete here this is going to be
my twin peaks' season 3 part 13 top
moments video it was a fun episode well
actually it started out fun got a little
dark and then it got mysterious if you
haven't watched part 13 yet this is your
spoiler warning this will contain
spoilers thus the title so the first top
moment big moment for me was the conga
line and the presentation of the gifts
to Bushnell by candy and if you thought
that Dale Cooper might be back to
himself when you saw him Kong going oh
how do you even say that conga Aang
along there we go
if you know he's back to himself they
were sure to throw in that little dougie
you need to call your wife and him
parroting the word wife so that we know
that he is exactly the same as he's been
next big moment was Duncan Todd's
reaction when Tony called him I have
mentioned before I love this actor in
the way he plays this guy and pretty
dire I suppose he told them he has one
day to remedy the situation
we knew that since the Mitchum's warmed
up to dougie after the thirty million
dollar check that Tony Sinclair would be
in charge of taking dougie Cooper out
and Duncan Todd made sure to let him
know he only had one day to do it the
next big moment was Naomi Watts and
heard pixon of Jamie E the reaction to
the yard Jim and the new car I really
enjoyed watching her face change storing
the scene I thought it was really good
and of course the very next moment after
she told them to put the Jim in the back
was seeing sonny jim in what has to be
the coolest gym in the neighborhood the
arch and the spotlight that seems to
just go around constantly are definitely
nice touches the next big moment was we
finally saw evil coupe again and my
favorite part of his reintroduction was
the guy saying to ray you didn't kill
him too good if you don't remember let
me refresh your memory
ray is upset when he sees evil coupe and
he tells the guy
that he killed him which leads to him
saying you didn't kill him too good
the next big moment was the guys waiting
upstairs for coop to get up in the
elevator this looks like my kind of gang
here lots of interesting characters and
of course the next moment after that was
the armwrestling match you had to wonder
how it was going to go down especially
after he gave evil Cooper shots at the
back of the head on the way into the
match I mean I don't think anybody
thought evil coupe would lose and the
way they built the suspense was great in
this team but no one could have guessed
how it would actually play out I mean
had he kept returning to starting
position and he told him it was more
comfortable I mean I was losing it so of
course he won the match promptly killed
the guy by punching him in the nose and
then he gets what he asked for and
that's Rey after having everybody turn
out their cell phones for him and ask
him for some privacy
the next big moment was him shooting Rey
in the foot when Rey tried to run you
really can't blame him for trying but
the accuracy and the speed of the shot
from evil coupe every time he does
something like this I'm like what's
going to happen when he runs into dougie
and then I would think about while
dougie did fine against like the spike
but this is a whole nother level right
the next big moment was Rey pulling the
I'll cave ring out of his pocket he says
the guard gave it to him when he had
never seen before so I'm not really sure
about that evil coupe tells him to put
it on his ring finger and then proceeds
to interrogate him about who wanted him
to kill evil coupe we already knew it
was Phillip Jeffries or the guy who goes
by the name Phillip Jeffries so this
wasn't new but he does mention that
because he wanted it done because he has
something inside of him which is
obviously Bob but the look on evil coups
face didn't tell me whether Bob's is
still there or not this has been kind of
an open question since the beginning of
episode 8 so we didn't really find out
for sure we did find out last he's heard
that Phillip Jeffries was at the
Dutchman
before you can finish his sentence he
gets shot in the head as this is all
going on the next big moment was Richard
horn showing up at the farm nobody
really seems to think he looks out of
place but we don't get any more
explanation of that it's interesting to
note that he's on hand to watch on the
giant TV screen with the rest of them
evil coupe shooting ray because Ray had
to LK bring on his left hand ring finger
he ends up in the waiting room after
he's killed and all we see there is the
ring being put back on to the table the
next big moment was the print they came
back the information that they had
attached to them was correct but
hilariously the flucos think it's a big
mistake because it's so unbelievable so
they followed up and bet a dollar
whether he can throw it in the trash bin
and in case you forgot he won the bet he
was able to pitch it so all that
build-up we had about those prints seems
to be on the back burner at this point
the next big moment was tony showing up
at the police station he goes outside
and talks to one of these dirty cops
that we figure is the one that's
involved with Duncan Todd and the
insurance scams he says he needs some
poison get a quick shot of cuts and
chantal driving there in Utah which I
guess means they're going towards Las
Vegas and the big moment here was
Chantal saying that Mormons don't drink
liquor don't drink coffee don't even
drink soda or have sex before they get
married
hutch adds that he heard that they can
get married to six to ten wives after
the fact which Chantal responds that she
can't believe there isn't more of them
then and she says it must be the drinks
the next big moment is the cherry pie
the poison the dandruff and the coffee
so Anthony gets his poison he offers to
buy dougie a cup of coffee out of his
eyes that YouTube seems some cherry pie
still he wanders off when he comes back
he notices dandruff on the back of
Tony's jacket which causes him to pause
and this is enough time for Anthony to
completely breakdown
and decide not to go through with his
murder
cherry pie figures into the next moment
right away as well
Shelley gets a call from Becky who says
that Stephens been gone for two nights
she's really upset
but then Shelley says why don't you come
on down here and I'll fix you up a
really nice piece of pie with a scoop of
vanilla ice cream and lots of whipped
cream and that's enough to make Becky
feel better and she heads over that way
the next moment after that was seeing
Big Ed for the first time Bobby had come
in to the Double R for dinner and we see
the big eggs they are talking to normal
he makes sure to tell Bobby there's
nothing going on and then the next big
moment was dr. Jacoby seeing the golden
shovel hanging in a deans window
stopping and then I'm having a very
sweet moment there it was a little bit
awkward if you remember Nadine was one
of his patients a long time ago but he
brings up this story about seeing her in
the supermarket trying to find a potato
on the floor they seemed to be very
mesmerized by each other's presence and
then we go over for a really bizarre
scene that Sarah Palmer's and I'm going
to be honest I have no idea what was
going on here I know that she was
drinking and smoking cigarettes and on
the TV there was a loop of a Fight Team
it's an old boxing match and it just
kept looping gonna have to look at that
a lot closer for the recap and review
that the next big moment was the Audrey
scene and this is the exact same thing
there seems to be something other than
what we think going on with Audrey
there's a lot of theories out there I
don't know which is the best fit really
but if we had suspicions in her first
appearance there's definitely this is
definitely fuel for the fire of things
are not what they seem with Audrey Horne
second then the next big moment was
James playing only you at the Roadhouse
like this has been an ongoing joke since
this season started that as soon as
people saw the Roadhouse and that there
were musical numbers the big running
joke is then that James would close
an episode playing this song and it did
actually happen now there's a girl she's
weeping in the audience as she watches
but beyond that I don't really know what
to say about this except for it was just
a perfect callback if people are
complaining this isn't Twin Peaks II
enough there you go that's straight from
the original run right there then the
final big moment is another scene that
needs some serious observation we see
Big Ed at his gas farm and he closes out
the episode it's a rolling credit scene
we haven't seen that he basically sits
there he's looking out the window
it appears that things may be looping
there too but like I said I don't have
to look at this a lot closer he catches
something on fire and that's pretty much
it so yeah I mean it was great to see
evil coop come back he's in Montana
Montana is between South Dakota and
Washington States on the way the farm
was a really bizarre place that I can't
really explain the coordinates not
really sure why ray had them written
down or why they well he would hand them
over seems like the way to stay alive
would be to lead him to the coordinates
but I guess technically that would be a
pretty hard thing to do but yeah we got
a bit of everything in this episode so I
really enjoyed it the mystery at the end
is going to keep the wheels turning all
week long I think because Sarah Audrey
and Big Ed are all pretty mysterious
teams they're another thing to keep in
mind that could be important is that it
was nighttime in Twin Peaks so another
day has passed the countdown the
Jackrabbits Palace is on didn't see any
Gordon or Albert in this episode so
hopefully we'll catch up with them in
the next one so yeah I'll be doing the
recap tomorrow sorry I didn't get my 10
things video out I didn't get any videos
out yesterday I wasn't feeling well and
there's really not much to do except
just try to get back on the schedule
this week so please give this video like
if you liked it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't done that already
make sure you turn on notifications so
you'll know when I upload new video
we're getting into the homestretch guys
I'm pretty excited so can't wait to hear
what you had to say in the comments
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon